foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
the shark army wants a civil war
now Jesus
do we have to explain to him
over and over and over again how this
[ __ ] works with the Civil War
[Music]
it's not surprising
that they're a little upset
oh
what a great day yesterday was we had a
few technical difficulties with the
broadcast but the hearing in general
went over well I thought went a little
longer than I that I was told I was told
it was about an hour went a little
longer than that
and then our after coverage was
fantastic I don't know if he wants the
after coverage
on the Midas touch Network and here on
the Tony Michaels podcast
but it was fantastic we had Michael
Cohen we had Rachel bittickoffer Dr
Rachel bidikoffer David Bender
Texas Paul Jessica Denson the legal a at
first Michael popock and Karen agnepalo
KFA
joined us for the after cover so go
check it out go check it out we had a
few audio issues in the um in the
pre-game that's on our channel here so
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
here on YouTube you can check out the uh
the pre-game coverage
it still exists there you can still
watch it
um it seems
been my zealous came on to um give his
two cents about the um Mike Pence clip
when he's talking about how it's not
illegal it's not illegal to take
criminal advice from attorneys
and he didn't he did an impersonation of
Mike Pence and it it killed the Audio I
mean a few minutes later the audio was
starting to crack I'm not sure what
happened I don't know if it was our
connection or what but it really started
the the
[Laughter]
the Mike Pence impersonation from Ben
mizellis started to crack the audio so
I'm not sure exactly what happened and
I'm not blaming it on him I'm blaming on
him no I'm just kidding I'm just kidding
it was it was a great it was a great
show we had a great broadcast we had
some hiccups we had to go to some
different links so I appreciate everyone
following those links and getting to the
right place to watch the hearing because
that really was the most important part
I mean yeah do you want to hear us
[ __ ] idiots talk of course you do of
course you want to hear a stock but the
main thing is is that you get the
information and yesterday we did have
new evidence I was very skeptical of
what new evidence they were going to
bring to the table for the criminal
referrals and the evidence that they
brought was testimony from Hope Hicks
and that was the testimony and I
expected Donald Trump to absolutely
[ __ ] attack her and burn her down
um I don't think he's done that yet I
don't know and he hadn't got to her yet
he's still in his drained straight State
excuse me his deranged State over Hunter
Biden's dick pics on on Twitter
he's absolutely convinced that because
Twitter moderated their platform Hunter
Biden's dick stole the 2020 presidential
election from him he's [ __ ] nuts he's
[ __ ] nuts people that's why I keep
telling you it is a good thing that this
motherfucker's running
I'm I'm telling you this kind of
craziness this kind of deranged state of
him and them [ __ ] being complicit
what the [ __ ] is wrong with them
well I tell you what's wrong with him
they know he's gonna win
that's what's wrong with him Mitch
McConnell comes out and does everything
but say his name
won't even say his [ __ ] name
and the reason why is because he is
going to be their nominee and they
cannot have audio of them saying he
can't be present he can't be our nominee
I'm not voting for him they can't do
that because they will
why do you think I warned you about the
[ __ ] America First Nazi party here on
our show they're all Nazis they sit at
the table with them
[ __ ] them
that's right Mitch McConnell is a
[ __ ] Nazi
you played footsie with him you are them
sorry that's just how it works
we should not tolerate this garbage
and we have to shed light on it but
again folks I am not afraid of Donald
Trump being their nominee frankly I
think it will absolutely destroy what is
left of the Republican party and that is
exactly what our political body needs
we need to rid ourselves of this [ __ ]
disease
and he's not going to prison anytime
soon he's probably going to be indicted
but just because he's indicted on
federal charges doesn't mean they tote
him off to jail
let me give you some hard truth when
they indict him they are going to let
him free that is what they are going to
do
they're not gonna lock him away in a
Cell in the meantime they're not
they're not
now the other significant piece of news
that I think came from yesterday again
these these uh these charges I believe
are these referrals of charges I believe
are a little ceremonial I think Texas
Paul he's going to join us today I think
Texas Paul disagrees with me a little
bit on that I actually think that this
doesn't make a hell of beans worth the
difference I don't I don't I don't think
Jack Smith gives two [ __ ] shits what
the select committee says what they do
what report they put together he only
cares about the evidence he's going to
thumb through it and he's going to make
the charges that he wants to make and
that's just the way it's going to be
I don't believe that a good a good
prosecutor and what I mean by that is
one that's gonna [ __ ] nail you to the
ground the person who's committed crime
gives two shits about what another a
political body in the Congress says or
does or what referrals they give now the
doj has a certain process that they have
to go through with these referrals
um but I I don't think that it's going
to make a shit's worth of difference of
what Jack Smith's going to charge him
with
and guarantee you he's gonna get to a
grand jury and he's going to charge and
indict this [ __ ]
that is exactly what's going to happen
now I the the charge of insurrection is
the most significant to me now this is
why Maga is freaking out they're even
posted on Twitter the 14th Amendment is
unconstitutional just laying bare that
they have no [ __ ] idea how our
government works how our constitution
Works how our country Works they are a
bunch of dumb [ __ ] they really
think that an amendment to the
Constitution is unconstitutional you are
a bunch of dumb [ __ ]
if you think a change that was ratified
by the states
into our constitution is
unconstitutional this is the same stupid
[ __ ] where grandpa Poopypants to Cheeto
dust q and honor is in full freak out
mode over these [ __ ] criminal
referrals
full freak out Mo we're I'm gonna show
you today I I don't go to True social
that much and show his statements you
know I we we try to post the ones that
are relevant most the time is just
[ __ ] deranged typing on his fraud
social network
but this this idea that he's putting out
this morning
that he has to believe that he won for
our vote to be valid you you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] ow you
[ __ ] you
we I don't give two shits what candidate
believes or what they don't believe or
what they're running around saying like
Carrie Lake don't give a [ __ ] our vote
is not Reliant upon your belief of it it
does it's not relying upon it you stupid
bastards
and it's not how it works that's not how
it's ever worked that's not how it's
ever gonna work you stupid [ __ ] that's
why you're so pissed off about this
midterm you're [ __ ] pissed about this
midterm so pissed that you [ __ ]
can't even get it together and get 218
for your [ __ ] leader in the Congress
you're a bunch of worthless pieces of
[ __ ] Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren
bobert are eating each other's faces off
over over they can't get to 218.
Matt Gantz is attacking his old
girlfriend
Marjorie Taylor green I guess they're
not America first [ __ ] anymore I
guess not I don't know
and if you're not politicizing it if you
are not politicizing the fact that
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
are about to burn down each other's
house and use Matt gatz that [ __ ] sex
trafficker alleged
as a as the [ __ ] gasoline you're not
doing it correctly that's what we're
gonna do here you [ __ ] a ride that's
what we're gonna do here because like we
said yesterday in the after coverage
with Dr Rachel bidikoffer and David
Bender because look the legal analysis
and all that [ __ ] for the for the
[ __ ] referrals fine whatever I I I
really don't give a [ __ ] about the legal
in that I mean I do care about what the
outcome of the legal analysis is but
here's the thing Jack Smith is going to
do the legalshit [ __ ]
he's gonna drop the legal hammer on
these [ __ ] and it doesn't
matter if it's Trump Eastman Clark it
doesn't matter if it's [ __ ] Michael
Flynn Steve Bannon Rudy Giuliani Jenna
Ellis Christina Bob it doesn't [ __ ]
matter he is gonna drop the hammer on
whoever the [ __ ] he needs to including
members of Congress [ __ ] the ethics
goddamn committee
the Chief of Staff Mark Meadows we keep
forgetting about that [ __ ] he's
foot for sure I'm convinced of it that
Mark Meadows has flipped and the reason
why is because he's not in the narrative
Dave left him out we've left him out
he's flipped [ __ ] that's it and those
text messages are the [ __ ] Trail
they're the trickle trickle of the
entire scheme
which the January 6 elect committee
believed there was a scheme that's why
they did the criminal referrals and then
they did the ethics referrals of course
Mo Brooks would have been drawn into the
to the ethnics referrals but he's not a
member of Congress anymore so [ __ ] him
what's the matter
if there's crime Jack Smith will sniff
that [ __ ] out
and drag Mo Brooks out from underneath
his [ __ ] rock
my guess is Mo Brooks is flipped too
they're all gonna flip every [ __ ] one
of them even Eastman they'll all do it
every mother [ __ ] one of them every
single one of them cash Patel Christina
Bob on the documents all the attorneys
that are under heat Rudy Giuliani Mark
Meadows
Don Jr Ivanka whoever knew whatever the
[ __ ] they knew and when they knew it
they will flip here
have you seen a picture of Jack Smith we
confirmed yesterday uh Karen ignifolo
KFA knows Jack Smith personally and she
confirmed that he does not eat nails for
breakfast but it sure as hell looks like
he eats bowls and nails for breakfast
this is not a guy you want to [ __ ] with
he prosecutes war criminals
think about this for a second war crimes
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me would this
be the prosecutor that you want to crawl
up your ass and live there for two or
three years [ __ ] no hails to the no the
last [ __ ] you want on your ass
but here he is
here he is
and Trump is terrified absolutely
[ __ ] frightened that's that's the the
story that I take
from his post on front social uh MJ our
great moderator pointed out because I
tweeted it
um
and and you know basically
I I tweeted two of them this morning one
of them was the one about how he he he
if he doesn't believe that he lost then
he didn't lose which again our vote is
not relying upon his belief of it
that is not how that [ __ ] works it's our
vote you [ __ ] idiot it's been
certified it was certified
but MJ pointed out the uh Brady act in
Florida
which he is a resident now uh the Brady
act allows uh loved ones to commit
someone to a to a uh you know maybe a
Mental Health institution
I don't know if Mar-A-Lago can be
converted into a mental health hospital
but maybe we should look into that I'm
just saying
um he's under a lot of heat other places
too the news today
a lot of heat these tax returns are
really [ __ ] oh man they're they're a
pain in his ass
these tax returns that the Ways and
Means Committee
may make public
he's really [ __ ] upset about it
and he's really worried he's not worried
about the crime folks and I don't know
if you noticed this but he thinks he's
immune from from crime and prosecution
he thinks he's absolutely immune from it
all he has to do is not believe he
committed crime and they can't charge
him with anything
that's what this dumb [ __ ]
believes
his tax returns are not about crime
it's not about money I mean there's
money laundering in there you can damn
well better bet that but he didn't give
a [ __ ] about that the thing he cares
about most is is this [ __ ] idea that
he's a billionaire and he's Rich that
motherfucker's broke broke as a joke
why do you think he sold the [ __ ]
post office in Washington DC hell the
only reason why he held on to it when he
was president is because he was making
money off of it when he was president
but now that he didn't have the
influence what the [ __ ] is the point of
keeping that goddamn piece of [ __ ]
sold that off he needed the money
and he's definitely gonna need money for
this receivership what do you think
these Trump trading cards are about
he's taking his I guaran damned to you I
guarantee him to you the [ __ ]
has taken donations that his supporters
have given to his political organization
and purchased
his own nfts as an investment some
stupid [ __ ]
and that's how I got to the 45 000 and
he pocketed personally all the [ __ ]
money he grifted off his supporters and
now he's grifting more off of him
because he's using some sort of exchange
apparently to [ __ ] sell these things
for 360 bucks
who is the dumb [ __ ] that paid
99 right for one of these [ __ ]
these trading cards [ __ ] out here with
this [ __ ]
nft my ass oh my God
stolen art is what it is and then and
then you're gonna turn around and say
that the value has increased over three
times and sell it for 360 bucks are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me I mean think about the
dumb [ __ ] that's spending 99 on
this sumbitch and then you know put the
image in your mind right I mean it's
Uncle Earl from the Q a on Facebook
group right the horse paste eating
[ __ ] over there on Facebook
that's the guy who's gonna pay 99 for
one of these or a couple of them maybe
but imagine
just imagine put wrap your mind around
now the [ __ ] that paid 360
dollars
for what
for some kind of [ __ ]
authoritarian fantasy get the [ __ ] out
of here I I just wonder I just wonder
how many of these nfts
that these [ __ ] idiots jerked off
dude that's what I want to know it's
it's it's their Trump porn at this point
but they love it they oh they [ __ ]
love it
and the reason why is because again we
have a disease in this country
and the Republican party is complicit in
the in the continuation
of the infection of the disease
it's there it's their baby so let them
own it and it's only up to us to make
them own it we we talked yesterday in
the after show too I I know I keep
bringing up the
yesterday's broadcast but my one of my
favorites my favorite political
strategist and and uh just a master of
messaging my friend Dr Rachel
bittickoffer
she made the point so well David Bender
asked her look did this stuff have an
effect did the select committee have an
effect
and she pointed out
so well
that in the in in 2021
when when we had the Virginia's
Governors right you remember the CRT was
everywhere [ __ ] CRT
if your coffee was cold or bad it was
crt's fault critical race Theory it's
all a bunch of [ __ ] just nonsense
but we didn't really have the apparatus
to get out in front of the [ __ ] thing
but she pointed out so well that
when they were polling in 2021 about the
governor's race in Virginia and CRT
it always seemed that CRT made it on the
list of [ __ ] that people were concerned
about because pollsters were asking that
nonsense
right remember we've been saying that
polls are a bunch of garbage they're
just [ __ ] trash they have no they're
Antiquated they do not do them correctly
it is all a bunch of garbage
these polls
you can't trust them I don't care what
Outlets it from it's from whether it's a
right wing whether it's a non-bias that
has a good history you just can't trust
them because they're wanting to get more
[ __ ] internet clicks than they are to
get a real [ __ ] answer for a poll
they don't give a [ __ ] about that they
don't give a [ __ ] about what is reality
and what's not anymore and they just
want the click they want to they want
the media to buy it hook line Sinker and
they want the click
and the thing that was going on in the
summer of 2021 in the fall was critical
race do you remember all these q and I
nuts these anti-backs are showing up at
[ __ ] school board meetings waving
their hands around wearing stupid
[ __ ] outfits talking about how spoons
stick to them they're Magneto now
and CRT critical race Theory they
couldn't tell you what the [ __ ] it was
but it was the greatest threat
to white people
since the last threat Joe Biden or
whatever the [ __ ] it was was the last
threat
to white people in this country
but here's the thing
Rachel pointed out something so great
that the polls in 2022 guess what guess
what was the number one thing people
were concerned about [ __ ] democracy
do you think they asked that question in
polls in 2021 for that [ __ ] Virginia
Governor's race hell to the no
they didn't
and that's the point that I try to make
here is that the messaging and the
narrative is so [ __ ] important and we
must politicize everything at every
moment no matter what even as disgusting
as it may be and really honestly if you
don't have the the wherewithal to
politicize this stuff in front of people
that's what I'm for
I'm the rodeo clown that's the whole
point
of this show right they got their rodeo
clowns they got their [ __ ] circus we
should have ours too
and that's the point and you should
share this far and wide ever that's why
I come here every day and yell and
screaming to this [ __ ]
is because we have to push a narrative
that we will not win we will not win
democracy without a message it won't
happen
we have Liberty in this country and we
have Liberty of the vote the problem
with that is a lot of stupid
[ __ ] vote a lot of them
and I'm not saying they can't be
convinced that our ideas for democracy
are better than autocracy they
absolutely can be convinced of that
but we have to do the work every
[ __ ] day
every single one of them because you got
a [ __ ] deranged [ __ ]
someone who wants to be the dictator of
the world down at Mar-A-Lago throwing
ketchup on the wall and [ __ ] in his
depends
you want that [ __ ] lunatic in charge
of anything apps I mean anything
he really shouldn't even be in charge of
golf courses to be [ __ ] Frank with
you let alone the goddamn government in
the United States
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
but it's more than just him
and it's clear now more than ever
they know the [ __ ] tried to
overturn our democracy they know he
tried to [ __ ] on the Constitution you
remember they came to the floor after
the violent Insurrection and every one
of them like this is the worst thing
ever that's ever happened this is the
biggest attack on our democracy since
the Civil War and then yesterday the
press secretary at the White House says
that [ __ ] oh oh well what about what
about 9 11 what about Pearl Heart those
weren't attacks on democracy
those were attacks on our country from
without
word dummies this is an inward attack on
our Constitution that you [ __ ] bone
hence that it protects are trying to
overturn it
because it doesn't suit your interest
anymore
that's why
we don't want to be a Christian Nation
you want us to be so you want to get rid
of the Constitution
you don't want lgbtq people to have
[ __ ] rights we think it is in our
Constitution that they have the right to
Liberty so you want to get rid of it
you do not believe that women have the
right to their bodily autonomy we
believe it we believe our constitution
protects it that's why you want to get
rid of it
it's really [ __ ] simple it's not hard
to understand what is going on I believe
gen Z gets it I've told you that over
and over and over and over and over
again and I'll continue to say it
because their generation understands
they understand what is at stake forget
forget a [ __ ] line item in a bill
forget that the Republicans have been
yelling and screaming about the middle
class and the oh they're they're
Starving in the economy and then they
vote against minimum wage increase
forget that yeah that's great oh oh
that's great great little quip that we
can use
it's about the fundamentals and the
foundation of our country and our
democracy
that's what it's about
until we rid ourselves of this disease
which is trumpism and it doesn't rely on
him folks
we will have a foundation
and our principles at risk
of authoritarianism of fascism of
trumpism taking over our country Jesus
Christ I watch a video this morning this
is so stupid
I can't even believe I can't even
believe that they think this makes them
relevant
Kerry Lake apparently the judge said
yeah we'll go to trial
and they [ __ ] thought they won this
morning they are acting like she's
like she's gonna be gonna be the
governor or some [ __ ]
really honestly the judge is not doing
Carrie Lake a favor by going to trial
with this
they're not he's not they're she's gonna
[ __ ] lie she's gonna say some crazy
[ __ ] those attorneys are going to put
themselves at risk of losing their
[ __ ] law license watch
hide and watch
you cannot make [ __ ] up you can't just
[ __ ] make up what you want to make up
it's not a thing and we watched it
yesterday
as as maybe insignificant
to the law and to charges and
indictments that these criminal
referrals may be
they are definitely significant in the
front front in mind of the American
people
I told you yesterday during the
broadcast
there are Americans out there that pay
no attention to American politics
whatsoever they're more worried about
who's going to throw the football on
Sunday
they heard yesterday that there were
criminal referrals to the Department of
Justice from Congress and they believe
Donald Trump is now charged with a crime
that is how severe
we have walked away from what is
important in our country
that people don't understand simple
fundamental facts and processes of our
government
but that is the reality that we live in
and to ignore it is to ignore the threat
to our foundation so we must we must we
must
lean in to democracy we can't just say
well we did a good job in 2022 they got
a small majority in the house we won
back Senate got it got an extra seat we
didn't we didn't give up these Governors
seats in these Secretary of States in in
these vulnerable swing States
we can
we have to say those were victories in
on on the battlefield of democracy and
we have to go in some more
every single day and you can you can do
that by coming here every single day
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch do not forget
to subscribe to the YouTube channel here
at the Tony Michaels podcast again all
even though we had those technical
difficulties yesterday all three of the
broadcasts are still up on my Channel
all three of them they're there just go
to videos and they're right there maybe
I'll make a playlist of them or
something I don't know so you can find
them easier but they're all three there
you can watch the parade coverage the
audio is a little touchy at the very in
about the last 10 minutes but we got we
have the the actual uh hearing and we
had the post coverage on the show and
yesterday I posted as the podcast on all
the directories which you can download
every single episode on Apple Spotify
Google yesterday the episode was the
after coverage episode 293 was the live
post hearing coverage uh I felt it to be
the best the audio was better
um so I and it was almost two hours so I
posted that as yesterday's episode 293.
I cannot believe we're almost to 300
episodes holy [ __ ] I guess if you do
this every single day you're starting to
racking them up I guess holy [ __ ]
well here's the thing
this week is Christmas
and I think Thursday we might do some
sort of Christmas show or something I
don't know what we'll do
I'm not really sure maybe we'll sing
some carols or something anybody else
out there in the Christmas spirit I mean
I I'm I'm an atheist so I don't really
believe in the religious part of it but
what part of Christmas is religious
anymore Santa isn't the religious Bart
the Christmas tree the most the [ __ ]
music which I like by the way is not
even adds anything to do with [ __ ]
Christianity they're so [ __ ] brain
dead they don't even realize it they're
like Merry Christmas you're like happy
holidays like Merry Christmas
girl
they don't realize that all that [ __ ]
that they want like all the decorations
and it's all Pagan
so but this week because it's Christmas
on the weekend what we're gonna do is
we're gonna have Friday off and Monday
off we're gonna take a little bit of a
holiday break
um so we're gonna go through tomorrow
and Thursday so Thursday will be our
last show now before next Tuesday and
for the holiday I'm gonna give ourselves
a little break take a little bit of
family time you know stay off social
media I've been doing that here lately
I've been doing that here lately when I
stay off social media a little bit yeah
for my mental health and elon's Twitter
is [ __ ] speaking of that go ahead and
follow us on to it on elon's Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod and you will be able
to vote on Thursday for bone end of the
week we will put out a poll for bone net
a week we just won't have a show on
Friday
so make sure to go follow that if you're
on Midas Touch Facebook page now you can
follow me at the Tony Michaels you
follow us there and then you can
download the Twitch app come watch us
over on Twitch if you like
I really appreciate the audience here we
we run on your support we would not be
able to do it without you you're the
greatest audience in the world if you'd
like to give a tip go to Tony Michaels
dot live look I used to do the super
chat on YouTube
they take too much of your [ __ ] money
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them so go to
tonymichaels.live and you can leave a
one-time tip or you can set it up
monthly just set it and forget it and if
you want something oh my gosh these are
flying off the shelf still it's getting
cold out there and boy it's gonna get
[ __ ] cold this weekend where I'm at
holy [ __ ] it's gonna be a cold
[ __ ] for Christmas go to store
not the Tony michaels.com that's
store.thetonymichaels.com you can get
hoodies sweaters I didn't even get you
some T-shirts depending on where you
live you know you might want a t-shirt
you might not want a t-shirt at this
point again it's getting pretty cold but
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty is the hot
one so go check out
store.donymichaels.com listen we got
Texas Paul waiting in the wings I'm not
gonna make him wait any longer we're
gonna talk about this Trump freak out
because he is [ __ ] his diapers so
someone needs to get down to Mar-A-Lago
and clean up the clean up the ketchup
and wipe his ass everyone stick around
we'll be right back right after this
[Music]
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
male do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product hard and blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
it's Tuesday Tuesday Tuesday yesterday
felt like a little um like three game
for Tuesdays with Texas fall because he
was uh I put him at the end of the
coverage with the me and Gabe Sanchez
yesterday it felt like the uh
felt like Tuesday yesterday at the end
of the coverage it really did take this
ball it felt like Tuesday there it
really did
how are you my friend you're on mute
there
yeah it was a good day yesterday it was
a really good day I mean I I have to say
I was surprised at the new evidence and
and the way everything unfolded they did
a fantastic job wrapping this up I
thought yeah I think so too well you
know um a lot of people you know the
media is [ __ ] they're [ __ ] idiots
they're all worried about what the hell
this uh um uh report on Wednesday is
gonna I was listening this morning
they're like oh well we'll see what
evidence they didn't bring out that that
favors Trump like you dumb [ __ ]
man what what on Earth what on Earth
could be evidence that that supports the
idea that this guy was trying to
overthrow our government what in the
[ __ ] evidence could there be it's like
it's like saying you know on the way to
the murder he opened the door for
somebody at the gas station and because
he opened the door at the gas station he
couldn't be that bad of a murderer for
crying out loud this is [ __ ] stupid
this is dumb stuff they're ridiculous
and honestly I I I was wondering how the
media was going to figure out a way to
be like how how is this bad for Democrat
how is Trump being uh uh referred to for
four charges of crime including
Insurrection the department how is that
bad for Democrats so ridiculous
[Laughter]
you're still on sorry brother I was just
getting into the in and I was about to
jump up and yell Hallelujah
the Quasi [ __ ] the crazy [ __ ] that's
going out there today is just amazing I
mean I would the first thing I I when I
opened my eyes this morning I clicked my
phone and you know first thing my phone
said was that why don't you go ahead and
punch that code in there buddy uh you
know when you wake up and your face is
all messed up and you can't you know
your phone won't even recognize you yeah
too much eyeballs yeah I was rubbing I
was rubbing everything out of my eyes
and I was and I opened my phone the
first thing I see is hanging is
apparently we're all scared of trump oh
really that's why yeah that's what's
going on in the right wing this is all
because we're terrified of trump
um that's hilarious and then the second
thing I ran into was a pretty organized
troll movement where they were pushing
revisionist history it was all off that
Trump tweet that you know when he was
[ __ ] his pants yesterday about how
you know he tried to rehash all the
oldie but goodies about he was being
spied on and Pfizer and all your right
yeah Jack Smith's gonna investigate that
and all this energy
well here's the thing here's the thing
is I would I would love to watch any
[ __ ] one of these right-wing idiots
come on my show and try to and try to
convince me that that that I don't want
Donald Trump to be their nominee I've
been saying it for [ __ ] weeks now I
was cheering when he announced I'm like
hell yeah I want he is going to destroy
you idiots I don't think you understand
how [ __ ] toxic this idiot is and
everything Trump touches turns to liquid
[ __ ] this is facts there's nothing out
there's nothing else this guy does but
besides destroy something he does
nothing else but destroy everything
everything around him he destroys why
the [ __ ] wouldn't I want that guy in
charge of a party that I want to [ __ ]
take a nosedive I I actually want him to
win
their Republican nominee and I I um
after thinking about this yesterday with
the timing on this
with the criminal referrals and I'm not
sure exactly when uh because I think we
disagree on that I want to Hash that out
a bit but um I actually think Jack Smith
is going to um to probably get the grand
jury to drop indictments on him sometime
between January first quarter right
um I I believe Jack Smith is going to
make sure this is lock tight whatever
whatever charges he brings to the grand
jury I think he wants those charges to
be the charges he's not going to want to
do a hundred Super Singing indictments
on Trump
um it just it'll give more for the chaos
machine to operate and to to just cause
[ __ ] havoc in the in the public
discourse um so Jack Smith is going to
be very I think he's going to be very
surgical about this and the charges that
he brings and the charges that he wants
and he's going to want those charges to
be the charges so
um but here's the thing thinking about
the timing of this let's say let's say
Jack Smith gets him in the first quarter
with these indictments and especially if
Insurrection is one of them right now
again I have said time and time again on
this show that him announcing was not to
fend off indictments he's long passed
that he's trying to fend off a trial in
2024 because his bet is because he can
still be on ballots even though he's
charged with Insurrection
um if if he's convicted of insurrection
he cannot be on balance it's 14th
Amendment he just won't be able to
appear on balance
um if they charge him and convict him of
that but if it's a beforehand thing
where he's just indicted he's on
pre-trial and he's running around the
country yelling and screaming at his
sheep and and he's and he's um he's
running for president he can be on these
ballots even though he's charged with
Insurrection some states may pass a law
where he won't be but that'll be in blue
States it won't make it hell's beans
were the difference the point is is that
I don't think Ron DeSantis will take a
chance right think about this first
thing in Texas Paul here's why this is
this is [ __ ] I'm telling you this is
fantastic this is going to destroy
desantis's political career too here's
why
Ron DeSantis is not going to take the
BET next summer to announce that he's
going to run against a guy who has
nothing to [ __ ] lose I mean he's got
if Trump is charged with Insurrection
here his only his only chance to get out
of it absolutely get out of it is to win
the presidency that's it there's no
other shot he got he has no other chance
at that point
now Ron DeSantis is going to do math
he's like okay I'm going to be the
governor of Florida until 2026 which
would be opportune time to start going
well maybe I'll think I'll run maybe
I'll think I'll run for 2028. why in the
[ __ ] would Ron DeSantis take a risk of
destroying his political career next
summer running against Trump so who else
is there Texas Paul who else tell me
um if I had to guess I would say uh
we're looking at dewine and Kerry Lake
and The Perennial candidates will throw
their hat in the ring
um you don't think Trump will destroy
those mothers
I agree they [ __ ] burned them to the
ground and piss on their ashes he I I I
I don't think people understand
I mean he's deranged now right he's
absolutely deranged now and he's
uncoupled from any sort of reality I
mean literally this morning he was he
was posting let me see if I can bring it
up here he was posting and I'm going to
go through some of these uh [ __ ]
statements that he had this morning but
um this one let's see this one here yes
I believe it's this one here yeah
um he had one about Hunter Biden's dick
but um oh that's not that's not what I
want ah damn it
Hell Boy while you're looking for that I
would just want to throw out there
you're forgetting that uh
um Greg Abbott wants to be our first
paralympian president and he's getting
older and this is I think Greg Abbott
will throw his hat in the ring against
that oh absolutely absolutely well I
mean um he may end up as running as uh
desantis's VP
that's how he ended up Governors he
ended up skating along with a stronger
candidate right so you so you believe
you believe that um
that it might not be DeSantis it'll be
Abbott the challenges in him next summer
which that that might be not be a bad
Theory there again DeSantis is a young
guy he's not an old dude he's got plenty
he's got plenty uh in the chamber for a
future career if he doesn't run in 2024
right and again the only reason why I
talk about this stuff folks is because
we have to politicize and draw wedges
just like bobert and Marjorie Taylor
green we're going to get to that here
soon Texas ball today
um about how these [ __ ] chuckleheads
right and they're in their little
America first [ __ ] boy
um uh Matt Getz the alleged sex
trafficker he's he's kind of in the
middle of it too which is even that
makes it even better but here's the
statement from
um grandpa Poopypants the Cheeto dusk Q
anoner this morning this guy is such a
[ __ ] idiot he literally types all
this nonsense out just to say if I don't
believe I lost then I can't lose which
is not a thing that has that the
candidate believing or not believing
they won or lost has not a goddamn thing
to do with the [ __ ] vote here's what
he says this is this is quote what he
says and it's hard to read but I'll read
it I see where the unselect committee
using the Democrats favorite weapon
disinformation I say yell it because he
has it capitalized
um is trying again disinformation
um and we'll get into that later I am
not going to get into that let's
continue he's trying to make the case
that I
is trying to make the case that I didn't
really believe I won the election
literally he says I didn't really
believe I won the election as if that
[ __ ] matters that has nothing to do
with it not a God damn thing rather you
believe facts or not they're not that
doesn't make them not facts it's not a
thing
he says this is a total lie again he
capitalized the line I never thought for
even a moment that the presidential
election of 2020 was not rigged or
stolen
it's almost like Rigdon stolen is the
name of like his like his horses or
something he capitalized them Texas ball
rigner stolen Who you gonna bet on
rigged or stolen today at the track I
don't [ __ ] this guy
um and my conviction became even
stronger as time went by
as he got more and more desperate Texas
Paul his absolute delusion that he won
the election got stronger and stronger
can you imagine that from this lunatic
Jesus Christ now with all the massive
evidence that has come to light
including the recent FBI suppression of
election changing information which is
[ __ ] stupid this Twitter files stuff
it was I was a hundred percent right but
in this statement what he's trying to
say is as long as he doesn't believe he
lost he won which
if that's the case if it only relies on
a candidate believing something to be
true then what about the fact that Joe
Biden believes he did win I mean this is
really stupid [ __ ] Texas Ball but it
just shows the links this guy's gonna go
to try to make a really stupid [ __ ]
argument
yeah and and you know I believe that I'm
prettier than Brad Pitt but you know
my wife keeps telling me otherwise
yeah you can you can say you believe
anything all you want but that's the
grip for his he's got that core base
that he's just trying to fellate and and
that that's what it's all about that's
what it's all about you know the
disinformation that they're putting out
and this is where we've got to do our
job key on what you were talking about
earlier this is why it is so important
we really have to pay attention you and
I have to pay attention to this very
closely because they are trying to you
know people have short political
memories they do
and if the they reach into their bag and
they throw a bunch of the [ __ ] back out
on the table that we've already batted
down the entire public has seen its
[ __ ]
you know you'd think that it would oh
well that won't stick but it will
because I know when I was reading the
[ __ ] this morning and I covered it
I was like what the [ __ ] is he talking
about oh yeah that you know I mean and
and I covered it I did videos on it I
did research on it you know so your
average layperson is going to see this
[ __ ] and that's how that works and
they're never going to quit he is never
going to quit not until he is in prison
or dead he is not oh and he's still not
he's still not going to quit um and
here's why is because even from prison
he'll be writing letters to people to
post out on social media as a statement
from him from former president Donald
Trump from [ __ ] Leavenworth or
wherever the [ __ ] they end up locking
this guy up at which I don't even know
what that looks like that's a whole
nother [ __ ] ball of waxing that's
years away because again I believe I
believe this whole chaos thing is a
stall tactic it's always a stall tactic
with him it's always to push the
argument and push the accountability to
another day and another time and he'll
keep doing it and keep doing it and keep
doing
because here's here's another one that
he posted this morning and that's what I
believe the the nfts while you're
looking that up the nfts that you were
talking about earlier yeah that's what I
believe that's all about is that he had
his organization
these were handled through an exchange
so that money went to Russia or wherever
I don't know the investigations will
show because this is going to turn out I
believe this is going to turn out after
they investigate it will turn out to be
a monthly money laundering operation you
can tell by the max number that they set
is just under ten thousand dollars per
transaction right so none of it has to
be reported
um you know think about it if your ass
is in a crack but you've got some liquid
Capital laying around you're going to
want to cushion you're going to want
money to operate on when the government
because the first thing that Jack Smith
is going to do is lock up the Trump
trump organization and say I got you
buddy you cannot use this money for for
anything so he's setting aside that's
leadership in the state of New York they
already have a monitor it's already in
receivership that's that's that's kind
of the [ __ ] crazy part is that Trump
organization just was criminally [ __ ]
um was found on 17 counts to commit
crime tax fraud which the bar for for
Tish James in the state of New York
for Trump organization and civil court
is much [ __ ] lower way [ __ ] lower
than the criminal and they found him
guilty on 17 counts it's going to be
easier for Tish James to tear down the
Trump organization in that civil case
than it was to charge them and convict
them in the criminal case
well and that's that's well here's what
I want to show you and this is why this
guy's [ __ ] freaking out and I believe
what you're saying about the nfts is
true is that all that is is to get his
liquid capital in his political
organization in his personal [ __ ]
pocket because he can't do anything with
his money in the state of New York he
just can't and they even got the ability
to for some of his other businesses
outside of New York but here's here's
that the Tweet well excuse me the post
the truth on fraud social right
um this is the one about Hunter Biden's
dick
and it it literally when you read it it
doesn't sound like that but if you think
about it in the context of the evidence
that Elon Musk gave us which is crazy
that the right wing gave us the evidence
that it the collusion between the
government which was the Biden campaign
and Twitter was the Biden campaign
reporting Hunter Biden's dick pics can
we look at this through the lens of
reality though he was President right
exactly that was his FBI right it was
supposedly doing exactly he was the
executive in in the branch that the F
that the FBI resides in which is the
executive branch under Department of
Justice here is here's what he says this
is [ __ ] again I know it seems like
this is irrelevant but folks this is
totally relevant to what is about to
happen to a former president of the
United States we've never been in this
territory before never and the only
reason why we are exactly what you said
yesterday Texas ball is he did this to
himself but here's what he says files
conclusively in all camps reveal that
the FBI totally discredit damning
factual information from Hunter Biden's
laptop from from hell to top Twitter
Executives prior to the 2020 president's
election what he's talking about is the
five links
that he has seen
four dick pics of Hunter Biden that the
the Biden campaign reported to Twitter
which anyone can report any tweet
anytime that's you do not need to have
special permission to report a tweet you
just go click the three [ __ ] dots and
you can report the son of a [ __ ] even
still even though Elon doesn't really
have a safety team at this point or
anyone to report it to the AI I think is
running their entire uh reporting
apparatus but he goes on to say quote do
not use this they said it is Russian
disinformation
also and again yq's pointing out it's
his FBI Donald Trump's FBI that
contacted Twitter and said this is
Russian disinformation
it's literally his law enforcement agent
and they had actually they had actually
looked at the data they they knew that
there were images added they knew that
there were there were emails they knew
the [ __ ] stupid laptop yeah and then
they well the hard drive that they're
carrying nobody's actually got a laptop
it's a hard drive wow right and mirrored
copies of it actually at this point are
what's circulating around it's not the
actual hard drive anymore
um but yeah the FBI had seen this
information they had seen the chain of
custody they know it went through
Giuliani they know [ __ ] was added to it
they know [ __ ]
evidentiary wise it's useless but if you
keep repeating it if you use that old
Joseph gerbils uh tactic of just repeat
it repeat it repeat it repeat it
then it becomes reality for the people
that want it to be well but in Texas
Paul that's the point of drawing wedges
and the mocking this stuff that's why we
have to mock the trump card cards that's
why we have to mock the stupid Hunter
Biden laptop the Twitter files because
it's all mockable it is ridiculous to
think that Twitter did something outside
their purview when they took down
pictures of Hunter Biden's big old hog
on Twitter when someone well they ought
to call that guy two guns man
okay so so here's the part that really
gets me in this post he goes on to say
also spread the word to other big Tech
and media companies and that that point
right there just makes it that that yes
the FBI and the Department of Justice
was concerned about actual Russian
disinformation because they just weren't
colluding with one company they were
they were quote colluding with all of
them which law enforcement does it's a
protocol for them and he goes on to say
it was not a request but a demand when
have you ever seen Texas ball have you
ever heard of law enforcement
um giving a request for certain
information when they're saying hey we
have we have this or we have that when
is law enforcement I mean you've watched
videos of law enforcement is there ever
a request I don't think it's ever
requested there's always a demand right
get on your knees put your hands behind
your back I'm requesting this I'm
requesting these things
when they first the first time you
talked to them sometimes they will say
uh would you like to give that to me
right right because if you just if you
just volunteer it saves a lot of
paperwork right right right right right
so it goes on to say whether they
believe it or not they had an excuse
not to use it against Biden again we're
talking about dick pics here we're
talking about dick pics of Joe Biden's
son's huge dick okay and he goes on to
say who this is the greatest [ __ ]
finish here I can't even believe that he
is talking about dick pics here and this
is the Finish who would have lost
millions of votes and rigged and and
stolen election it is crazy that this
guy believes
it's rigged and stolen right because you
can talk well in the last one he
capitalized the first letter that's why
I thought it was like names of horses
rigged and stolen right
um but here he's obviously screaming
because no one is hearing him he's he's
screaming into the void can you um
listen
what I always wonder when I'm [ __ ]
reading these things is
I want to know what he looks like when
he's is he sitting on the [ __ ] is he
getting his diaper changed is he is he
about to hit a drive on the on the nice
hole I I I I want to know what he's
doing while he's there I guarantee you
he's smacking down cheeseburgers as fast
as you can right now he is emotionally
eating right now yeah man he's throwing
it thrown into his Burgers now nothing
would please me more than for him to
choke on a [ __ ] Big Mac at this point
nothing would please me more
you know before we lose track of that
topic you know you breaking it down
beautifully but again let's look at it
through the lens of reality talking
about this last one yeah yeah the one
you just pulled up there let's look at
this statement through the lens of
reality the reality was that yes every
news organization in America including
Fox [ __ ] news
had this information right and they did
not go with it for a reason because it
was tampered with because they could not
rely on the information it doesn't
matter that Donald Trump and this is
where you and I this is the only thing
I'm angry about this is the only thing
I'm angry about
after the election I wanted to take some
time off I like as you I've been doing a
little less social media I've been doing
a little woodworking you know [ __ ] like
that I wanted some time off I thought
maybe me and the wife would go fishing a
few times [ __ ] like that no
I'm [ __ ] dealing with this
misinformation and it's pissing me off
and they keep saying things and and it
will become true if we don't counter it
if we if you and I don't do our jobs
this will become true and he's just he's
gonna say it over and over and over
again and we always have to
put it back in that lens of reality the
[ __ ] news organizations
knew it was [ __ ] they knew the hard
drive had been tampered with they knew
there was nothing that they legally
could put their name on
right well and and
listen the complete utter delusion of
all this Steph including Hunter Biden's
lamp top the Trump trading cards his
derange went down at Mar-A-Lago while
he's posting on true social this is all
mockable and that's what we have to do
right now we have to mock this we have
to you guys is there someone in the
comments
oh yeah Rick hot got it I'm a big Gene
Hackman fan he got it salute to you Rick
I'm glad you got the quote Texas Paul
quoting jeans they got my two guns quote
Tommy two guns
[Laughter]
um here's here's more um evidence of
their derangement uh Piper for Missouri
um has this uh she's she ran for office
um I've actually talked to her
personally
um she's a huge Josh Ollie hater which
um we mean around the show I yeah yeah
well I I plan on getting her as a guest
on the show at some point but Piper says
here she's pointing out she said Jesus
Christ these folks which she's being
nice really Texas ball she's being nice
it's Tara price I don't know this this
writer look at this
writer
gun lover
anti-feminist America First Nazi in her
bio oh this this should be beautiful
let's hear let's hear the bright
statements of Mrs price here Jesus
Christ she says no
and I don't know what she's talking
about but it doesn't matter because the
next statement is just utterly
ridiculous the 14th Amendment is
unconstitutional Jesus [ __ ] Christ Is
Right Piper what in the [ __ ] how how
have they gone down this delusional Q
Anon hole so far that they don't know
that how an amendment
to the Constitutional works that's all
they talk about is freedom of speech
which is the first one and I mean Jesus
Christ she has it in her [ __ ] bio
here she's got in her bio here gun lover
so you know she's a 2A bro you know she
is so what in the [ __ ] how in the [ __ ]
do these people not know how an
amendment to the Constitution works that
it's ratified by the states which
becomes part of the Constitution they I
mean they hate the 14 for many reasons
but it is absolutely
mind-boggling to me that this person who
is claiming to you know I don't know who
the [ __ ] she is but she is she on Blaze
TV is that what this is she says Blaze
Stevie I don't know this is she says
you're no idea but here's here but the
14th Amendment is unconstitutional
I'm gonna go to this post Jesus Christ
she's getting ratio like a [ __ ]
look at this oh my God uh 316 quote
tweet 16 likes you know what the problem
is though yeah what's that
is that she's not
to say she's not wrong is the wrong way
to put that
um just she is not
wrong in our [ __ ] up scotus reality
put it that way okay uh look at what
John Roberts just did title 42 is set to
has been knocked down by a judge the the
judge quite correctly said you cannot on
one hand say we do not have a covet
emergency we don't need masks with
mandates we don't need School shut down
we don't need uh mandatory vaccinations
we don't need anything with covid and
then turn around and say you can suspend
due process for human beings because of
covet
you can't do that that the judge rightly
called that out
shut it down and and Greg Abbott was
screaming you can't take title 42 away
from my fascist [ __ ] ass because if I
actually have to to treat human beings
like human beings and give them due
process under the law well then I can't
be as big a dick as I want to be
and they tried to you know took this all
the way to the Supreme Court and John
Roberts
who this is a clear-cut situation I mean
this is not a hard legal there are no
deep nuances to this at all the
government that is arguing
you know covid's not a problem needs to
adhere to that reality if they're going
to argue that you can't you can't have
it both ways John Roberts issues a stay
and keeps title 42 in place
so if you don't know what title 42 is it
means that when somebody comes across
the southern border you don't have to
give them any kind of due process you
could just throw them in a box drive
them to the border and shove them back
across
title 42 is put in place under the Trump
Administration
for coven reasons correct when we were
in the middle that was the excuse that
was the excuse they use it used for
title 42. well it's actually part of the
protocol when you shut down schools and
everything else title 42 has a
legitimate purpose it does but you
cannot say covet is not a problem and we
don't have to have any actions in place
but the suspension
of due process you know you can't hold
on to that one thing because that makes
us fascist I mean that's what separates
a democracy from fascism is that people
have rights in a democracy and you you
give people due process under the law
you know here just to have law
enforcement acting unilaterally there's
a saying we have here the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty we have that saying here
honey Tony Michaels podcast
um and and I think that encompasses the
entire idea that you're that you're
stating and back to this this but what
what does that have to do with this 14th
Amendment her mindset right this whole
nothing is solid anymore Tony these
people anything is on the table as
stupid as this is the 14th Amendment to
the Constitution which is part of the
Constitution right is unconstitutional
right it's ridiculous it's ridiculous on
its face you don't even have to go into
what the fourth 13th Amendment actually
does which the 14th Amendment delivered
us our modern country like the our way
of life today is almost delivered to us
by the 14th Amendment but and that's why
they [ __ ] hate it but here's the
thing is that it doesn't even matter the
substance of this amendment she
literally does not understand how an
amendment works because of this
statement but and it doesn't matter who
this person is the point is that
it absolutely absolutely is [ __ ]
weird that we have people who claim to
be you know Patriots or what was her
[ __ ] what was she saying or what was
in her bio okay let's look at it again
who claimed to be gun law America First
it just shows you what the ideology is
that that America First means white
supremacy it does not mean Constitution
it doesn't mean that flag that's in
behind you Texas Paul it only means
[ __ ] white supremacy that is it
because that's the thing they're [ __ ]
heard about the most here is this they
literally lifted that from the clan
right they literally lifted that from
the KKK
well and here's the thing we we both
grew up in very white rural areas
um we have experienced whether we knew
it or not white supremacy and and
structural and institutional racism we
benefited from it it's our privilege
Jesus Christ we're both white men for
crying out loud but here's the thing is
that that is what really confuses them
the most they do not understand that you
do not lose your privilege when there is
equity and equality you do not lose your
privilege just because someone gains the
privilege that you have in an equal and
Equitable way doesn't mean you lose it
but that is how that's how white
supremacy operates and it's how classism
between whites operates as well we've
talked about it on the show that the
town I grew up in there were no people
of color were the white people racist
there [ __ ] yeah they were racist but
they didn't have anyone to be racist
against so it go it went to a class type
system right it was white classism and
there were there were were whites that
were better than other whites in the
town because they didn't have anyone to
be superior to so they had to be
superior amongst themselves and that's
the craziest [ __ ] deluded part of our
American culture and it is built
absolutely built on the foundation of
white supremacy folks and white
privilege and if you're not aware of
that you haven't been paying attention
you just have not been and and and
that's that's where and again I know it
sounds crazy that that her statement
that the 14th Amendment is
unconstitutional is racist but it is it
is white supremacy is what she's talking
about fundamentally
you know and CRT whenever they mention
CRT they're not talking about CRT
they're talking about the propaganda
propagandize history that you and I grew
up on
you know imagine me being a kid and how
shocked I was when I found out that
Robert E Lee wasn't a [ __ ] genius he
was a [ __ ] a complete [ __ ] he was not
a great military leader he was a guy
that would put his soldiers through any
[ __ ] thing and did not care what
happened to them he made his Chaps in
the Mexican-American War because he did
[ __ ] to his soldiers that other
commanders wouldn't do
I mean literally the decisive battle
that made him a hero he ran his entire
you know company of soldiers ran them
right through a [ __ ] Cactus patch the
the Mexicans they were fighting thought
covered they're flank because nobody
would be stupid enough to March through
it oh no Robert E Lee would do that to
his soldiers he would you know and then
you every battle in the Civil War the
only battles he won he was on the
defensive on his home ground every time
he went somewhere you know he lost his
ass he made stupid [ __ ] mistakes the
guy's a [ __ ] but not to get off on the
weeds that's the point that is what
they're talking about they want to
preserve this status [ __ ] quo
and as you're saying Tony the it is the
idiocy of that is immeasurable because I
do not lose anything because someone
else also gets it but that's and it's
even the opposite of that you actually
preserve your Liberty by making sure
making sure that margin Alliance
Community receive their Liberty it
protects your own how the [ __ ] can't
they how the [ __ ] can't they understand
how rights freedom and liberty works it
is the opposite of what they're saying
and it's the upside down and it's the Q
Anon world that we live in because it
really is a q Anon World we're just
living in it um because the Q and honors
don't even realize that they're pushing
a Neo-Nazi demand a real domestic
terrorist narrative and we watch this
[ __ ] with the lgbtq community and and
well the bipod Community too but here
recently with Matt Walsh the daily wire
Tucker Carlson going on and on and on
about trans people and trying to make
every single lgbtq person An Enemy of
the State and an enemy of God and
whatever the [ __ ] [ __ ] they want to
spread around but here uh in Moore
County we talked about it was it last
week or the week before [ __ ] they get
away from me here Texas ball now Moore
County know and they they there was a
attack on their power grid and I think
there was a shut up stations right they
said shut up substations right it was a
strategic attack to shut down uh an
lgbtq event by turning off the
electricity essentially
um and and I think they ended up cutting
power to was about 40 or 50 000 people
in Moore County yeah I believe that was
the number 43 000 people if I remember
correct yeah somewhere somewhere in the
40 50 000 range uh Raw Story is putting
out a story this morning has obtained
exclusive chats leaked by an infiltrator
that show Neo-Nazi
um they were discussing and Adam Waffen
off offshoot now Adam Waffen are Nazis
this is not in the context of when I say
Matt gatz Marjorie Taylor green and Nick
Fuentes are America First Nazis they
self-identify themselves as Nazis these
are real [ __ ] neo-nazis the this is
not them trying to separate themselves
from Kanye are trying to separate
themselves from like you said the the
America First of the KKK this they are
truly 100 outright in front Nazis
um now this offshoot uh is called
they're called the National Socialist
resistance front does it sound familiar
the National Socialist resistance front
again they they're identifying
themselves there as National socialists
which we all know that's how Hitler
self-identified the Nazis
through the lens of reality just because
you see the word socialist there right
they weren't [ __ ] socialists they
were fascists that that took over a
socialist party right just like just
like the fascists are taking over the
Republican party doesn't make them
[ __ ] Republicans at all it doesn't
make them conservative not even close
that's why I call them the America First
Nazi party okay so
um has been tied to more counties so it
is this Adam Waffen offshoot the
National Socialist resistance front
which it's basically Adam often and the
reason why is because the FBI and the
domestic terrorists
um I I believe there was three Adam
Waffen members that were arrested
um what was it uh it was back in the
spring when they threatened there was a
threat to
um a water a water system somewhere
um and Florida I believe or Georgia I
can't remember there's so many of these
things and they actually uh arrested
those and charged them and so of course
there's an offshoot you know they got to
change the name got to Rebrand you know
that's that's what's surprising about
the proud boys and The Oath Keepers to
me is they haven't rebranded yet even
though they're [ __ ] seditious Traders
uh in court they're proving to be but it
seems as if raw story is undercovered uh
chant leaks that this group
um where this comes from where where
this whole ideology comes from this is
an international thing guys right this
is not this is not homegrown this is
this this comes directly out of Russia
which supports white supremacist groups
worldwide they have give them given them
strategic plans
the idea behind it is and this is why
this is actually scary that they're
doing these test runs
if they can take down the power grid
that shuts down your water supply
they are armed to the teeth they then
assume control
that is that is the step by step
function of this you cannot operate for
more than two days without water
you cannot as a human being operate more
than two days without water
if they take down the power grid the tap
water you rely on is gone
there are backup generators that will
run for a few days and that's it
then they can assume control that is the
plan that is the scary ass [ __ ]
strategy that they have put together and
for too long you have people that are in
the Republican party that were way too
complicit and did not want to act
against these people because they're
their people they vote their way
folks the Republican party will not
protect you they will not they need
these scumbag [ __ ] wads because
if if you took away the Electoral
College not to get into the weeds or
anything the Republicans could not be a
national party
they couldn't they couldn't survive
they wouldn't they would never win a
presidential election they would never
own the White House again
well under their current state at least
yeah and and and they have to have these
radical ass groups that's why they will
not come out and speak against white
supremacy they will not come out and
speak against
any of their supporters at all because
they're barely holding their house
together we're kicking their ass and
they see it disintegrating their game
plan has to be attack our ability to
vote and hold their Coalition together
and these [ __ ] are their Coalition
they are the root of it and and the
sheriff
in that county is [ __ ] worthless
because he is part of these [ __ ]
organizations parade
he went and prayed with the suspect and
decided through that prayer he knows she
doesn't need to be investigated
[ __ ] she's a former military
intelligence and she is exactly the
person that these [ __ ] organizations
recruit
they specifically go for these people
and they're good at it folks they are
trained the Russians have excellent
psyop organizations they may not be able
to have infrastructure out there but
their human capabilities are huge and if
you don't think so
look at Maria boutina
she was in the upper echelons of the
Republican party in a [ __ ] Russian
spy
folks I know I've thrown a lot out there
like like spaghetti on the wall that you
know what I mean but I'm realized we are
in this age yeah
these people are [ __ ] dangerous and
this was a test run this really was a
test run they know that if you can wipe
out
power in New York City
it will be chaos in a week
right it will be complete and utter
chaos in a week because 12 million
people cannot move out of the city
we cannot get
the water into the city
they will be engaged in a [ __ ]
Guerrilla War they can literally
paralyze most of New England
and the Russians have been training them
to do it well you know you know who else
the Russians have a hold on
at the Republican Party well uh Marjorie
Taylor green
um oh my God it is it is insane how
um absolute
um entrenched in Putin she is but
speaking Marjorie Taylor green there's a
little bit of a feud going on Texas Paul
and I want to take advantage of it of
course I want to take full advantage of
it what I want to do is I want to drive
these wedges as deep as I possibly can
here's what I mean by that and we I
politicize the [ __ ] out of everything
here I'm not scared of it
um I think we should it's part of the
national narrative I do it so you don't
have to the the viewers the listeners
out there I do it so you don't have to
you can just say look look what this
chucklehead said maybe we should listen
to this you know I don't know share
around the clip but here's the thing is
that they absolutely cannot figure out
who's gonna be speaker they can't Kevin
McCarthy is today is not going to get to
218 today by January 3rd he may make
enough deals and sell off enough of his
speakership
um enough of his power and speakership
to be get to 18. I think that's how he
has to get the 218 is he has to sell off
all the power in the speakership
um but he'll but he is so he might get
there
but they're all in fighting right and we
should encourage this and not only
encourage us we should drive wedges this
is Matt Gantz a little clip of Matt
Gantz talking about Marjorie Taylor
green and the speakership let's listen
and then I'm gonna go to the feud
between bobert
and Marjorie Taylor Green Let's listen
your colleague congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor and he's gonna be speaking here
you I was really smoothies when you were
traveling and touring around various
places in Florida and other cities she
is actually backing McCarthy he doesn't
deserve her this is so great I love
Marjory Taylor green I think that she
would be a terrific speaker or leader
you know Marjorie is often reflected her
frustration with Congress as an
institution how corrupt it is how
there's no planning and oftentimes Kevin
McCarthy is the embodiment of the worst
features of the Congress so um I don't
begrudge her that not all two people see
all things the same way every time she
and I see this differently but trust me
we're uh allies we're in the fight
Marjorie Taylor green is going to be one
of the folks no matter who the speaker
is holding him accountable and making
sure that we're getting after it okay so
Texas ball here's what's important about
this clip is that Matt gatz knows that
people like me and you are going to use
this [ __ ] narrative that they're at
each other's throats to drive wedges and
we're gonna we're gonna try to destroy
the America First Nazi wing of the
Republican party which is the entirety
of the party at this point that he knows
that that's why he's hedging his betting
there when he's saying oh well just
because we disagree on this issue
doesn't mean doesn't mean that we don't
get along and we're not allies because
that's that's the little bit of evidence
that he needs because I'm about to show
you a clip where him and bobert are
actually at are burning Marjorie Taylor
Green's house to the ground but respond
to this clip if you will first
can you hear me there
where he's saying she would make a great
speaker which is [ __ ] laughable on
its face Marjorie green has no clue the
process of the House of Representatives
and when absolutely [ __ ] tanked that
son of a [ __ ]
yeah she'd be great for us you know I
mean she's right right she was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I mean she really is she she has
no self-control she says the stupidest
[ __ ] in the world she would alienate 80
of the country
immediately right I mean but but the
problem is there would be so much pain
and and and tragedy and and it would be
horrific for the country I'm glad to see
that the Republicans aren't willing to
go there
um
and it's just sad Tony it's sad the
debate here isn't Kevin McCarthy or a
strong conservative leader which I can
fight with a conservative what what
conservatives are left in the Republican
party though yeah which put the argument
in right the argument is
Kevin McCarthy the [ __ ] weakling
jack off versus the most radical
elements of the Republican party like
Marjorie [ __ ] Taylor Greene
they can't prove it I believe she's the
[ __ ] bomber from January 6th right
there's evidence to to assume that but
she can't get to 218 neither can Andy
Biggs or any of these other [ __ ]
weirdos and crazies and Q and honors
they're not going to get to 218 either
this again this is why it's so important
for us to talk about this as opposed to
talk about Joe Biden's successes Joe
Biden's successes are going to get right
in your pocket right you ain't gonna
have to talk about it much they're just
gonna happen it's it's important for us
to talk about this 218 thing and the
reason why it's so important to
understand
why in our history in our timeline in
this modern time right now why it is so
important that no Republican can get to
218 none of them is because that's how
the legislative body works you have to
whip votes that is exactly how it works
it works no other way the House of
Representatives will be stalled we will
have a government shutdown in September
Garen damn to you I don't care who this
speaker is
I haven't been talking to any of any of
the people I know in the house about
this and I really need to bring myself
up on the speed up to speed on the
negotiations of this but we need to be
we need to be courting Kevin McCarthy we
do he's he's got the most votes right
now he's having to go far right to
secure his speakership we need to kick
we have conservative Democrats we need
to have them quietly urge uh you know
minority leader Jeffries needs to be
quietly moving votes into the McCarthy
Camp to get him to 18 because Kevin
McCarthy
politically is great for us because he's
a [ __ ] [ __ ] but he'll be such a
shitty speaker but he is not Marjorie
Taylor green and we don't want him owned
by her you know I mean it's just hey man
I just sent you a link yeah I just sent
you a link and I'm my my theme is look
at it through the lens of reality if you
bring up that link
scroll down there's a map there that
clip we just watched was from turning
point USA's America Fest yeah that this
is this is Charlie Kirk's organization
by the way yeah that's Charlie Kirk's
organization and I want you to keep this
in mind as you watch this folks for the
audience
what I'm about to show you here where
Tony's pulling up for you right here
this map are schools
all the pins you see this is what you're
saying they're high schools in college
high schools and gallages they're high
schools and colleges
these people this is not a grown-up
organization you know that that that's
out there you know this isn't this isn't
some conservative movement organization
these are high schools and colleges well
they call it the student movement for
Freedom uh on over 35 exactly these
people are funneling this [ __ ] that you
just saw directly to your kids
Matt Gates the
[ __ ] pedophile [ __ ] that took
a 17 year old girl across state lines
for the purposes of paying her for sex
is the allegation that seems to be
paying in that I don't know why they're
not Prosecuting that [ __ ]
you know Green has done has spilled the
T on him
this is the guy they're funneling to
your kids schools
you know this whole organization is
designed to create and create another
generation of Republicans look at that
[ __ ] through that [ __ ] lens when you
watch that clip
he's not talking to me and you Tony he's
talking to our kids well and the other
thing that I want to point out here
um on this map is because you know you
they they get to this land vote [ __ ] but
even this map on their own website shows
um that it's it's only population hubs
um are where schools are so it it
clearly shows where the majority of
people are but I wanna I wanna make
Texas balls Point even more clear here
if you just look at like the state of
California here if you think California
is is full of a bunch of Democrats and
liberals and laborators look what he's
trying to do in this state look how many
different organizations how many
different pen drops he has around this
state to try to make sure that that
they're influencing out of this state
um which is you know important when you
put in the context that that
California's blue and it'll always be
blue and you know you can count on it
you can't count on anything can you text
as well not a goddamn thing no it's
always a fight death taxes and the
stupidity of this little [ __ ] let me
let me bring this clip back up
um I think you know the [ __ ] I'm
talking about you ever seen a rooster
be out in the yard you know bobbing its
head and it's pissed off it's ready to
fight
reminds me of this this [ __ ] and again
this is from America Fest from turning
point USA being funneled to your kids
right now I'm gonna play this short clip
she had a whole [ __ ]
um monologue of stupidity right and and
she's really got on the whole Jesus
thing I don't know if you've noticed
that but in the last really six months
since she was running for that seat and
she barely won by 500 votes
um which Marjorie Taylor green points
out but
Lauren bobert has really got on the
Jesus train like Jesus this Jesus that
it's kind of it's kind of a she needs to
quit Congress and be a pastor somewhere
one of these crazy traitor TV networks
or one of these um these Evangelistic
you know white supremacists white
nationalist churches but here here's a
short clip
of Bobo the Clown and
make y'all proud we're going to make
America proud We are going to weed out
the Deep State and that includes the
sorry Department of Injustice
[Applause]
Department of Injustice yeah I just want
to point out here that the proud stuff
the proud proud and then and then the
Deep State [ __ ]
um again this is all this is all [ __ ]
can't calls to Adam Waffen this is all
cat calls to stochastic terrorism a
white supremacy of neo-nazis in this
country and she's recruiting your kids
right right now right on on turning
points USA so that's a short little clip
just just a little hint of the stupidity
of Lauren bobert now you would think
that someone like Marjorie tether green
or Matt Gantz would buy into would buy
into that type of stupidity Texas ball I
mean it's their type of stupidity but
now they're competing okay they're
competing for control like you said of
the America First Nazi party it is super
important that they have the ability in
the House of Representatives to talk
about Hunter Biden's lamped up and how
the January 6th directionists who are in
prison convicted tried and convicted and
sentenced are political prisoners it is
super important that they want to talk
about this stuff and the reason why is
to distract from the 2020 winner of the
election Joe Biden to distract that he
that that Donald Trump lost to Joe Biden
that's what the hunter Biden laptop dick
pics is about and then the the
insurrectionist that their political
prisoners is to divert from that they
are criminals they were participants in
the January 6 Insurrection they are
insurrectionists they may end up as
prisoners and they do not want to be
treated like the Department of Justice
as Lauren bobert says Department of
Injustice
is treating those defendants now I want
to um bring this up here and margin
Taylor green tweeted a three uh tweet
Thread about
um her Feud with Lauren bobert at this
same event
this is at the same turning points USA
event now I said to marjorie's little
thread here I said if you're
pro-democracy politicized the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of this inviting of these
nincompoop Nazis because they are
nincompoops and you'll see what I mean
here's what she tweeted let me see if I
can get it a little better on the screen
Marjorie Taylor green tweeted this from
her official account her official
congressperson account not her personal
account this is very important
I've supported and donated to Lauren
bobert president Trump has supported and
donated to Lauren bobert Kevin McCarthy
has supported and donated to Lauren
bobert she just barely came through by
500 votes now these are shots fired and
this is the clip that caused her to
tweet this this is Lauren bobert and
Matt Gantz being interviewed by Charlie
Kirk and um is it Jack prostate here I
think is the one who is interviewing him
yeah I guess it doesn't really matter
but watch their response when they're
talking about Margaret Taylor green and
Kevin McCarthy because we've seen Matt
gatz kind of softball it and put it in
the context that they're still allies
but watch Lauren bobert's dumbass go on
the attack this is important someone who
we all respect Marjorie Taylor green
says Kevin McCarthy is going to be a
great speaker I I guess you'll have to
ask Marjorie about that I'm a fan of
hers I'm an admirer but it's not
something we see the same Lauren well
you know I I've been um aligned with
Marjorie and accused of believing a lot
of the things that she believes in I
don't believe in this just like um I
don't believe in Russian space places
are you a heart no face lasers and all
of this no I'm just saying we actually
have an inside conversation and and make
sure that these promises are there now
if you didn't notice the look on Jack's
face oh I'm sorry if you didn't notice
the look on Jack's face here
and Matt Gantz is she's saying that you
are not paying attention to the politics
that are at play here and they
understand Matt gatz clearly understands
and Jack here clearly understands it
Charlie Kirk's trying to talk her off
this ledge that what she is doing is
giving me
giving me and Texas Paul and any other
pundit out there the best gift ever in
the history of ever ever because how
irrelevant is Lauren bobert and Marjorie
Taylor green if Kevin McCarthy wins this
speakership like Texas Paul was saying
really [ __ ] irrelevant but when we
draw wedges for the 2024 election
because folks in 2024 it's just not
about the presidential election we're
gonna have some Senate races and we're
gonna have all the house races and she
lost by or she won excuse me by just
about 500 votes that district is going
to be 100 takeable
from Lauren bobert she knows it and she
has to start she has to start raising
her National profile again to run in
that District again and what better than
Margie Taylor green and Texas Paul this
is a gift I see it as a [ __ ] gift
what do you think
oh it is absolutely the more they invite
the better it is for us I mean there's
no way around it and and the hilarious
part of it is is watching the people
it's like the trolls and the comments
that are in the comments right now we
just picked up a fresh batch of trolls
in the comments their entire purpose is
to try to not look like total [ __ ]
losers because they got their dicks
kicked in in the last election I mean
that's the whole point of this they're
all over Twitter this morning there's
one guy in here Olson who was all over
[ __ ] Twitter this morning he's
nothing but a [ __ ] control he went
through Twitter this morning pumping
[ __ ] out about uh you know
all of this we're scared of trump
[ __ ] it's like the cat being scared
of the [ __ ] mouses he slaps it around
they're [ __ ] losers man just giant
losers you're gonna lose again in 2024
folks and it's not gonna be stolen
either we're just gonna kick your ass as
usual because you're [ __ ] horrific
you back people that say things like
Jewish space lasers that's hilarious man
what a line that's the [ __ ] train
you're on what what a line she had there
Lauren bobert because you've seen Matt
Matt Gantz again try to softball it when
when Charlie Kirk serves it up to him
right puts it on the T Matt Gantz could
have totally [ __ ] torched Marjorie
Taylor Green in that moment and he
didn't because he understands who we are
he understands the punditry of the left
they know they know we're coming for him
they know we are not going to tolerate
intolerance anymore they are terrified
that the Democrats in this country are
backed by [ __ ] pro-democracy
messaging folks we're not I mean me and
me and Texas ball here maybe I maybe
Democrats but more than anything we are
pro-democracy and our messaging is
pro-democracy and there's only one party
at the current time that that benefits
it is the Democrats and Nazis like Matt
gatz and Margaret Taylor Greene and
Lauren well not as much Lauren bobert
because that's the point I'm going to
try to make here is that they understand
they understand that we now have a
narrative we now have messaging and the
problem that they really have is the guy
they love the one they want to be the
dictator he's the messaging that we're
winning on
that's the messaging that we're winning
on so they don't know how to react and
Lauren bobert does something in true
dummy style where she basically gives us
that serves us up a big piece of cake to
eat and Gobble up for the next two or
three weeks
um because everything but it's important
Tony it's important it is important we
have to keep you know again I'm pissed
off about this I wanted to take some
[ __ ] time off I wanted to enjoy
myself for a while we can't Tony we've
got to keep at it we've got to keep
banging away because these people and
again
Charlie Kirk was the guy in that video
he funnels this to your [ __ ] kids
you need to be screaming down at your
kid's school get Turning Point USA out
of my kids [ __ ] school you've got to
get it out of your kids school they are
this guy is not trying to get
information to you me or anybody to
convince anybody of age he's funneling
this [ __ ] to children
and children are easy marks man all you
got to do is make them think they're
smart and they will believe anything you
say
you know and this guy knows it they
packaged this [ __ ] really [ __ ] well
people I'm telling you Charlie Kirk is
[ __ ] dangerous he's grooming your
kids well he he was he paid for turning
points he's gonna stay paid for I don't
know how many buses of people to go to
the insurrection I mean he was paying
for the people to be on the ellipse to
go and listen to the Cheeto dusk you in
honor and cite them the violence
um speaking of um people they're packed
absolutely did you're right it was I
think it was six bus loads of people
they sent to the January 6th well it was
turning points USA a few other groups
that were in on it uh but uh Jeannie
Thomas's group being one of them helping
turning points you say here's uh Ron's
got this uh video here
um now Carey lake is basically
irrelevant she showed up at this Turning
Point USA and I could show the clip and
I might hear after this this little this
little ditty here um but do you know
Wendy Rogers is you talk about
irrelevant you know Wendy's Rogers is
she's another one that gave us a gift
she gave us that video of maybe we've
been living in a bubble yeah I think I
think you were on the show when we went
through she's like yeah well here she is
back in the bubble decks as well because
um this morning the judge didn't
immediately throw out Carrie Lake's
lawsuit um in a hearing this morning
which is he's likely to throw out at
some point
um as this progresses because it's just
all [ __ ] but he's willing he's
willing to play ball with their delusion
at this point but Wendy Rogers is at
some sort of [ __ ] Nazi rally here you
can see the Cheeto desk you and honors
in the background not Gary Lake but
anyways when you Ed Ron says Wendy
Rogers announces that the judge didn't
immediately throw out Kerry Lake's
lawsuit and then Maga puts their
weirdness on full display this is this
is kind of [ __ ] crazy
um when we watch it here let me see if I
can let me see this
go ahead no go ahead go ahead I'll get
you on the other side okay let's let's
play it here again this is Wendy
reinders making a statement uh about the
judge not immediately
um
um 86 in Carrie Lake's case we are going
to trials
[Applause]
[Music]
this is hilarious
[Music]
[Applause]
three
ready
[Applause]
okay this is a good example of how they
eat disinformation like chocolate cake
because the fact is is Wendy Rogers said
they're going to go to trial which is
not exactly true right but that's not a
lie it's not a lie that they're it would
be a lie to say that they're not gonna
go to trial right at this point because
the judge
the judge is just just pushing along go
ahead go ahead I am [ __ ] loving this
I am loving this this is this goes back
to like like when Trump requested the
special master and then Giuliani did the
same thing before him but they didn't
[ __ ] learn
um you know like Trump requested that
special master and he's like oh I'm
winning oh by the way will you pay for
this no no we won't you'll pay for it
and you're gonna hate what this [ __ ]
does to you you know I mean we were like
every and they're like oh we won we got
a special Master you just kicked your
own dick in is what you did there and
Carrie Lake Carrie Lake doesn't [ __ ]
get
how this Rift works you know you think
there's nothing ever nothing ever goes
to court it's like the election they
said a bunch of [ __ ] but didn't take it
to [ __ ] Court
because if you take it to court right
all this [ __ ] has to be proven and then
a judge admonishes you and says you
didn't prove [ __ ] right
this is such a [ __ ] lose for Kerry
Lake well and again but it's
disinformation in front of your eyes
right because here's a room full of a
bunch of just
delusional Q Anon nut bags right that
will believe anything Wendy Rogers
speaks into a microphone and the fact is
is that this case that Kerry Lake wants
which again you're saying she does not
want which is she does not want this
case because it's only gonna [ __ ]
hurt her
um and her narrative and make her even
more irrelevant If You Could Only
Imagine but here's the thing is that
Wendy Rogers is says a piece of
disinformation into the microphone right
she says it right into the microphone
with a bunch of Q Anon Gary Lake
supporters in the room and they eat it
like it is the best [ __ ] thing that
they've ever eaten in their entire life
because the fact of the matter is is
that the judge just didn't kick this
case that's all that happened it was the
preliminary they didn't kick the case
it's it's they're probably gonna kick
this case once um they have more
hearings and they present what [ __ ]
what case they have right yeah when they
make when when they when they file a
motion for it to be dismissed they'll
kick it you know right right it just it
just it's Insanity it's Insanity that
that in this moment these people aren't
going wait a second is it really going
to try them because again it may or may
not at this point the judge is not
ruling it out that it's probably not
going to but the judge is not ruling it
out that's the real piece of Truth here
but again Wendy Rogers is using that
piece of misinformation feeding it to
these people and immediately they eat it
because it it supports their narrative
and this is why we have to mock them in
this [ __ ] moment we have to mock them
in the moment because three weeks from
now Texas fall three weeks from now when
this case probably gets kicked out or a
month from now we're gonna go back and
we're gonna try to play this clip but
these people in this moment they're
gonna make up some other [ __ ]
reason why carry lake is winning right
in this moment because that's right
that's what the whole clip was about it
was just about we won something oh my
God everyone
we're not losers we won yeah you didn't
win [ __ ] you didn't you this is the
worst thing that could happen for Carrie
Lake this is the worst thing that could
happen for Carrie Lake she does not want
this to go to trial then she has to
prove all the [ __ ] that she's been
saying and she can't she can't and she
looks like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you know it's it always always
always go to Twitter go to any of the
social media platforms it's the same
[ __ ] thing they're trying desperately
not to look like the big [ __ ] losers
they are you know oh we're winning we're
winning we're strong ooh speaking of uh
big [ __ ] losers
um did you see this poll that Elon Musk
put out
did you see this I am so glad that
you're bringing this up well I wasn't
gonna go because we couldn't talk about
it yesterday we had the hearing going on
um I think Elon Musk was brought up a
couple times in the coverage again if
you're here watching
um subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast on the channel here on YouTube
we have all the coverage from
yesterday's hearing the pre-coverage the
actual hearing and then the post
coverage on my channel here you can see
all of it right here on the Tony
Michaels podcast or hit subscribe and go
to the videos tab you'll see all three
of them there the post coverage the
hearing and the pre-coverage so we
brought him up a few times yesterday but
I wasn't able to talk about him so I
want to talk about this poll this
election that uh
I'm not scared this is [ __ ] hilarious
so here's what I suspect Texas poem uh
Elon Musk was summons to the World Cup
um and there was an image of him and
Jared Kushner and the Saudis that he's
probably in honk too
um in in this at the World Cup again I
believe he was summons there I don't
think he went there on his own he was
talking about last week how if he if
someone tweets his location it's doxing
which he tweeted himself look I'm at the
World Cup which is doxing his himself
which is really [ __ ] ridiculous but I
think he was summons to the World Cup
and the reason why he was summons there
Texas ball is to be told hey you need to
find someone else to run this
[ __ ] because here's the thing
everyone thinks that Elon Musk um goal
here is to take down Twitter I don't
believe that's the case there's no way
the Saudis threw in their money for this
much influence like on a social media
platform like Twitter and expect that
Elon Musk is just gonna crash this thing
into the ground that was not that was
not their bet here definitely not their
bet did they Saudis do not want to give
up a piece of
um uh social media influence like they
could have in Twitter right so I believe
he was summons there to be told you got
to step down you got to find someone
else to run this thing you're destroying
the [ __ ] thing you're just you're out
of your mind
so he sends out this this poll right
and this is what the poll said should I
step down as head of Twitter I will
abide by the results of this poll now
you can clearly see the results after 17
and a half million votes that's a lot of
votes on a poll Texas ball almost 60
percent said yes and it's not even close
because you know as well as I do you get
a poll out to 17.5 million votes it's
going to be within a few percentage
points this ain't even close this is
this is 15 [ __ ] points man all right
that is a that is that is bigger than
Reagan's blowout in 80. I mean it
you know that was I think that was like
seven points or six points this is
[ __ ] 15 [ __ ] points man he won
every single state back then now now
here's the thing is that this morning I
believe
um it's uh business and someone's
reporting this morning I forget the uh
the source someone's reporting this
morning that he is actively looking for
his CEO and he has been there's no way
that Elon Musk you know we talked about
this a lot wants to run Twitter anymore
and it's not fun right this is not fun
for him he's getting booed when he goes
places
um he's running polls like this
expecting for people to [ __ ] fluff
him for his Bots and his simps to fluff
him and they're not they're just not
it's not happening
um and he he is he is in a dire
situation with Tesla I'm going to show
you that too uh while we're talking
about this but I said I said you still
on the [ __ ] there's an old saying
that went around in my house Texas ball
it was a [ __ ] or get off the pot you
ever heard that yep absolutely sure get
off the pot Elon that's what I was
trying to say there is hey man you need
to [ __ ] or get off the pot on this you
need to announce the the CEO now he sent
out a few more tweets he was like ah be
careful what you wish for and that sort
of [ __ ] so who do you think that's what
I want to know Texas well who do you
think is going to be if Elon steps down
and he appoints a CEO to run Twitter who
do you think it's going to be
I have no idea I'll be honest with you I
can't even Hazard a guess there because
you're looking at the same situation as
trying to be a coach for the Cowboys
with with Jerry Jones involved I mean
it's like you're never really 100 the
coach you've always got that co-coach
with you you know it's it's going to be
the same thing for whoever takes over
Twitter because this is really too much
Twitter
that [ __ ] broke Elon Musk man I mean
emotionally it broke Elon Musk I'm
getting booed at the Dave Chappelle
event oh that's all part of it that's
where it stems from he knows it because
you know Elon moved to Texas right so he
had been listening to right Wingers
forever and they told him you got to get
out of California man you got to get out
of California come to Texas we love you
Republicans can't govern they can't do a
[ __ ] thing they're [ __ ] losers but
they do know how to suck a Billionaire's
dick they can do that well they told
Elin everything he ever wanted to hear
in his life and he has been spending the
worst of the worst Republicans out there
Abbott Ken Paxton Dan Patrick all of
these guys have been fellating us can
she come to Texas and that's what's
interested why I said we've got to
unfuck his mind because that's the [ __ ]
that's been
piled in his ears for the last couple
years and Elin really believed you know
old Wendy Rogers maybe we were in a
bubble
Elon Musk really believed that he was
going to come to Twitter he was going to
throw this [ __ ] sales pitch out of
free speech and everybody was going to
love it
and everybody was going to love what he
was doing with the company because he's
going to make it profitable and this
that and the other and he could not
believe
the reaction he got he just couldn't it
just [ __ ] broke him right emotionally
you know and then which we're talking
about with Twitter I mean Tesla I'm
sorry which we're talking about with
Tesla Tesla stock from in January was
over 400 a share
I believe today it peaked under 150 I'm
not I'm not sure I haven't checked the
numbers yet today but he was scraping it
was like 150 and a quarter yesterday
um this was this was at three yeah it's
under 150 now 145.80 and his investors
are revolting on him they are revolting
the biggest the board isn't we have to
worry about here because the board other
than Larry Ellison are completely
appointed and owned by Elon Musk but the
investors in Tulsa and Tesla I keep
calling it Tulsa the investors in Tesla
will sue the [ __ ] out of him they will
go around the board and these are people
with deep [ __ ] Pockets that are not
tied to one or two companies for their
wealth this is old money wealth where
they can really they can [ __ ] lot
Brinks trucks at Elon Musk you know off
of trebuchets if they want to fight with
me well and that's what he was getting
in to circle the wagons that's what he
was getting when you saw him there with
Kushner and everybody he was getting his
ego stroked and he was also being told
it's okay let this one go they're not
giving up on Twitter as a propaganda
platform the whole Twitter files this is
this is also Elon Musk in self-survival
mode because Trump this was all part of
a plan this was all part of a plan this
was part of the his inner circle this
upper echelon Republican group had a
plan they were going to put these
Twitter files out we were all going to
be shocked and yada yada and they
thought this was a winner man they
thought this was a winner and Trump's
all over it if you look at his tweets
today nothing but Twitter files man he
is just all over it well I mean they
they need the distraction uh is the
man's elin's seeing this [ __ ] failure
and what it's doing to him and he is
grabbing the parachute and Diving he
will have his fingers and what goes on
at Twitter but he's going to separate
himself from this this was all part of
his [ __ ] plan and he believed their
[ __ ] that people would love him for
this that's the thing you look at the
trolls in the comments here they believe
that people love them for what they're
doing
you know they believe that they're
they're better than everybody else and
and that's the same [ __ ] when Elon came
into Twitter he was nothing but a
[ __ ] troll
he didn't even understand I mean look he
didn't let him understand he didn't
understand the basics of Twitter as a
hub for social media you use it I use it
everybody uses it to link to other
platforms and that brings everybody to
Twitter to look for what I produce and
what you produce and everybody else all
the great creators out there Twitter was
a great Hub to go get the information
because we all linked it there which
gave Twitter engagements for everything
you and I [ __ ] did on any other
platform you know five or six different
platforms that we're on WE linked it all
through Twitter and Twitter lived off of
that [ __ ] and Elon Musk turns around and
says you can't link anything off of
Twitter
well they changed that they duck tailed
and run them and ran on yeah they did
immediately because somebody explained
to him how social media [ __ ] works
well I actually think he got a personal
call
um from a lot of big names including uh
Jack Dorsey but um this little exchange
here with uh Elon and his simps right
um this semp here they're talking about
the poll that I just showed earlier
where he was voted out as CEO on Twitter
right now rather he abides by that poll
or not we'll see
um they that again this morning the news
is there's a source that is saying he's
actively looking for a CEO I actually
believe that's what his World Cup
meeting was about I'll tell you that
here about that here in a second
um unfiltered boss here with a probably
a paid blue check says blue subscribers
should be the only ones that can vote in
policy related polls we actually have
skin in the game and Elon Musk
replies back good point Twitter will
make that change so in other words
there's a poll tax now over at Twitter
and that's how that's how much free
speech they want at Twitter is you have
to pay to vote especially when it's Elon
um putting out a poll and then these
[ __ ] this is crazy [ __ ] I don't
know
I I have no idea if these [ __ ] people
are real or not but this is crazy yes
only people willing to pay of course
this person and I'm talking about this
guy down here but that this person know
nothing says yes he's pointing out the
correct thing only people willing to pay
you eight dollars for a blue check
should be able to vote that will surely
be more accurate indicator of what the
average user thinks about you selling
free speech for eight dollars a month of
course no nothing is important that guy
is really wanting us that guy's really
want a sarcasm font right right right
right right right so so but here's the
thing this obviously this paid blue
check David Norman chimes in at the
bottom this is where we're at with these
[ __ ] white trumped up simps Elon
simps these P these people are
absolutely out of their minds they do
not understand anything at this point
they're so upside down
he'd post and I believe he's serious
here I pay a lot more than that for free
speech what the [ __ ] Texas ball what in
the hell is this dumb [ __ ]
talking about right he literally types
out he really types that on Twitter
underneath Elon Musk now of course he's
he's trying to like you said give Elon
felicio here because elon's tagged in
this thread I'd pay more than that for
free speech holy [ __ ] I just
it is okay look up what the word [ __ ]
free means right and then relate that to
having to pay for the privilege of
speaking
I do not know why these [ __ ]
can't put simple [ __ ] together like that
and they open their mouths and they say
stupid [ __ ] like this I mean could you
imagine being you know somebody's
married to that [ __ ] [ __ ]
I mean somebody has to go throughout
their day and this [ __ ] leaves the
house off a leash and goes and lives
their lives and affects your life
somebody's married to a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that would write things like I would pay
more for free speech
look up what the [ __ ] word free means
you dumbass free means you don't have to
pay for it it really is some stupid [ __ ]
I'm looking for it before we go because
I got two other things I want to talk
about here one one with this as you say
Elin the Elon Musk poll uh for Twitter
all right for CEO Twitter
um because Snoop Dogg if I can find that
[ __ ] thing here I don't know if you
you know who Snoop Doggy Dog is right
yeah why are you looking for that twit
files is is imploding
spectacularly oh well let me do my trump
hands it's it's it's incredible it's
amazing it's it's like nothing anybody's
ever seen before how spectacularly twit
files is [ __ ] imploding and Elon Musk
doesn't want his name associated with
twit files anymore so he's going to
appoint a CEO who's going to be amazing
and he's going to he's going to he's
going to be like nothing anybody's ever
seen before and Twitter's going to be
just incredible folks incredible folks
better than the chocolate cake at
Mar-A-Lago
it's going to be incredible oh God damn
well Snoop Dogg chimed in on this uh
who's gonna run Twitter and I you know I
I'm not I'm not saying that we should
abide by a Twitter poll but I'm saying
that this Twitter poll doesn't look half
bad 81 out of 3.4 3.4 million votes said
Snoop Dogg should run Twitter
um at least for a couple days that's all
I'm asking for is let Snoop run that
[ __ ] for a couple days at a bare
minimum now I want to go back to this
meeting
at the World Cup because I believe Elon
Musk was uh summons there he was meeting
with Jared I actually believe that is
the person in the in the top of the
running that is going to run Twitter is
Jared Kushner
um I know that sounds crazy a lot of
people think I'm probably [ __ ] crazy
for saying that but um I believe that
Jared Kushner was there for a reason
Elon Musk was there for a reason and
there was Russian propagandist and
um um uh Saudis there for a [ __ ]
reason they were all in the same place
in a public place for a [ __ ] reason
and the reason is who's gonna control
and who's gonna run Twitter because I I
believe the Russians and Saudis uh way
overestimated how smart Elon was way
over way overestimating how [ __ ]
smart he is they have no idea how much
of a [ __ ] bonehead this guy is and
they now realize it and they know they
made a big [ __ ] mistake
um backing this guy and putting him in
charge of this that is one thing I I
realize but I want to show you
um because we had Michael going on the
coverage yesterday speaking of Trump's
children and Jared Kushner
um Donald Trump Jr responded uh to
yesterday's hearing uh and I want to let
me ask you who do you think's the like
the the leftist of the left icons I mean
who would you say is the leftist of the
left icons I mean just the biggest names
I mean like look I don't know just just
pull something out of the air I mean if
you had to talk about a left Warrior
somebody that you could just use their
name and credibility I mean who would it
be like a left Winger yeah well Obama I
mean Bernie Sanders I mean okay take
Obama take Obama okay this is what the
Elon Musk and Kanye and the rest of
these [ __ ] can't figure out
these [ __ ] were using Elon musk's
they thought he had an
undestroitable brand they thought he was
beloved
that's why he was recruited
that's why they brought him into this
whole Twitter files plan this whole this
whole plan to try to keep the right wing
alive because face it the Republicans
pandered to these [ __ ] they
really do in every single way they
Pander to them they get everything they
want when Republicans are in charge and
it costs them nothing
so
think about it who on the if you had
somebody on the left like Obama and
Obama starts turning around and and and
and talking to Nazis and and and
bringing up Nazis and saying you know
you got to listen to these people you
got to listen to their ideas that's that
and the other
Obama would go on the [ __ ] sewer so
goddamn fast and I love that guy look at
look at Tulsi gabbard there's another
one there's policy yeah she was a
darling she was a [ __ ] darling when
she came out everybody on the left loved
her oh yeah
you remember that guy Andrew Yang yeah
he's in the toilet now
everybody they cannot understand on the
right you know they thought oh Kanye
that's bulletproof man so many people
love Kanye
they recruited him they told him what
they needed to tell them to get just
them to listen to his [ __ ] [ __ ]
and he went out and and they didn't make
an inch they didn't they didn't move the
front lines in this war and inch all
they did was [ __ ] destroy Kanye they
[ __ ] destroyed Elin and and Kanye was
did it voluntarily England did it
voluntarily but people need to
understand this they need to learn
before more people destroy I mean Elon
Musk has destroyed his brand
and I don't really honestly don't know
if it can be rehabilitated at this point
but he has destroyed his brand they will
continue to recruit other people Tony
they're not going to just oh stick with
Elin six months from now there will be
another dumb [ __ ] that believes
the [ __ ] that they say because they
really can't suck a Billionaire's dick
they really can right and I mean
it will happen over and over and over
again and and I don't know what it's
going to take
for people to understand that is not a
way to do business that is not a way to
move forward do you want to see what
it'll take here's a good example of that
Michael Cohen does a great job at
responding to Donald Trump Jr's tweet
here and then I'm going to show Liz
chain one clip of Liz Cheney before we
go
um because we're running out of time
here Donald Trump Jr tweets yesterday
um after during I think this is during
or no no no this is this is the day
before the lead up to the criminal
referrals he says just a friendly
friendly reminder that 80 FBI agents had
timed to police free speech and memes at
Twitter but no one had any time to look
into Jeffrey Epstein's black book
sexually exploiting children okay now
watch this this is this is I'm telling
you this is what this is how we do this
Michael Cohen you love him hate him
whatever you want to do he perfectly
shows the American people
how to absolutely use their own words
and dunk on Fascism and disinformation
and Q Anon and just this Hunter Biden
Twitter file [ __ ] and Epstein just all
the nonsense here's what Cohen says two
at Donald Trump Jr
as someone who you used to listen to
stop talking you are aware your dad is
in the black book
oh my God oh
[Music]
my God thank you Michael Cohen for that
uh Great Piece of content and an example
again this is a pro a prime example of
how you use reality to mock these people
he is absolutely making a fool and a
Donald Trump Jr rather Donald Trump
knows it Junior knows it or not I want
to end on this note uh before we go
Texas fall because
um out of all the people who spoke
yesterday I really believe that Liz
Cheney was going to be the one who did
the referrals for Donald Trump but it
was not it was Jamie Raskin
um who announced the referrals
officially in the hearing and then they
voted on those those referrals those
four charges
um that they want to refer to the
Department of Justice I really doubt Liz
Cheney would probably do it but she
actually did one better and it's only
it's not that long
um but I want to play a little bit of it
here let's listen
January 6 2021 was the first time one
American president refused his
constitutional duty to transfer power
peacefully to the next
in our work over the last 18 months the
select committee has recognized Our
obligation to do everything we can to
ensure this never happens again
at the beginning of our investigation we
understood that tens of millions of
Americans had been persuaded by
President Trump that the 2020 election
was stolen by overwhelming fraud and we
also knew this was flatly false we knew
that dozens of state and federal judges
had addressed and resolved all manner of
allegations about the election
our legal system functioned as it should
but our president would not accept the
outcome
among the most shameful of this
committee's findings
was that President Trump sat in the
dining room off the Oval Office watching
the violent riot at the Capitol on
television
for hours he would not issue a public
statement instructing his supporters to
disperse and leave the capitol despite
urgent pleas from his White House staff
and dozens of others to do so
members of his family his White House
lawyers virtually all those around him
knew that this simple Act was critical
for hours he would not do it
during this time law enforcement agents
were attacked and seriously injured the
capital was invaded the Electoral count
was halted and the lives of those in the
capital were put at risk
in addition to being unlawful as
described in our report this was an
utter moral failure and a clear
dereliction of Duty
evidence of this can be seen in the
testimony of President Trump's own White
House Council and several other White
House Witnesses
no man who would behave that way at that
moment in time can ever serve in any
position of authority in our nation
again
he is unfit for any office and there you
have it um Liz Cheney absolutely bearing
Donald Trump in the trash can in the
trash bin of what he would want to be
his legacy and absolutely destroying
whatever Legacy he thought he had left
she she absolutely buries him there so
um and it was kind of the exclamation
point on yesterday's hearing to be quite
honest what's your take on in Texas Paul
uh you know Donald Trump responded to
this by putting up two tweets that he
put out the day the the attack one uh
you know one saying respect the Capitol
Police and another tweet saying be
non-violent
um but if you look at the time stamps on
the tweets uh they were at like 3 30 324
or something like that uh Ashley Babbitt
was dead as a doornail
when those tweets came out you know look
at things through reality
you know Donald Trump is responding to
this trying to say well I called for
peace and calm and said yeah you called
for peace and calm after you watched it
all [ __ ] day after he knew it wasn't
gonna work that's the fact we called for
the peace and for them to leave after he
knew his coup attempt was not going to
work it wasn't good I don't know how to
I don't know how to make it any more
real or any more graphic but we had
already watched the stretcher come out
with Ashley Babbitt's [ __ ] corpse on
it
when he tweeted those tweets they'd
already rolled her down the [ __ ]
stairs
you know so just just to give people a
[ __ ] time Mark of reality to hold on
to
this you know I she
I don't like Liz Cheney I don't like
this change right I don't like her but
she's spot on here she is spot on here
Donald Trump should never be near any
office ever he should never be near one
in the first [ __ ] place and you
[ __ ] right he's oh it's a goddamn
apology for that [ __ ] and you should be
helping us fix this [ __ ] [ __ ] instead
of fighting us every step of the way
clawing with your goddamn Nails trying
to hold on to any bit of power you can
when you're [ __ ] losers
well what a way to end Today's Show uh
Texas Paul calling the right wing uh
losers because that's exactly what they
are and as long as they keep with their
loser King than they are losers
everybody make sure you subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast here on YouTube go
follow us on Twitter at Tony michaelspod
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify Google your favorite directory
also follow us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels Texas Paul you got a show every
single week uh so go follow Texas false
Channel I'll put the description I'll
put the link for his channel down below
so make sure to go follow Texas fall
Sunday morning coffee with Texas ball
and then watch his show and support
pro-democracy speech everywhere
same time same place tomorrow remember
we'll be off Friday and Monday for
Christmas but tomorrow same time same
place Surf's Up [ __ ] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn had asked Beacon